what a day this has been in the middle
of a partial government shutdown Speaker
Nancy Pelosi she was all set to leave on
a jet plane
well actually a US military plane on
your dime embarked on a seven-day
excursion with other Democratic members
of Congress that is until President
Trump pulled the plug in a letter the
president wrote Nancy Pelosi due to the
government shutdown I'm so sorry to
inform you that your trip to Brussels
and Egypt and Afghanistan has been
postponed we will reschedule this
seven-day excursion
when the shutdown is over in light of
the 800,000 great American workers not
receiving pay I'm sure you would agree
that postponing this public relations
event is totally appropriate I also feel
that during this period it would be
better if you were in Washington
negotiating with me and joining the
strong border security movement to end
the shutdown obviously if you'd like to
make your journey by flying commercial
well that would certainly be your
prerogative I look forward to seeing you
soon
and even more forward to watching our
open and dangerous southern border
finally received the attention funding
and the security it so desperately
deserves we'll keep in mind this letter
comes roughly 24 hours after speaker
Pelosi called for the State of the Union
to be cancelled because of some phantom
it turns out concerns about inadequate
security due to the ongoing shutdown and
of course we now discovered Nancy Pelosi
never ever not once reached out to the
Department of Homeland Security or the
Secret Service before making that
announcement now both departments had
long been planning for the joint address
they were fully prepared and Nancy
Pelosi made up those concerns why
obviously a political ploy political
gain and a political show rather than
actually negotiating a real border
security deal and an opening of the
government now she was just perfectly
happy to take a government-funded plane
and a government-funded intercontinental
trip instead of just staying in
Washington DC and actually doing her job
now keep in mind her seven-day absence
from Washington that would have
guaranteed the hundreds of thousands of
furloughed
federal workers they would miss their
next paycheck it would have been
impossible to get it so she obviously
doesn't care about furloughed workers
she only feigns moral outrage because
she had no intention of being there to
solve the problem today on the hill the
House Minority Leader Kevin McCarthy
backed up the president's letter 100%
rightly so take a look
being Speaker of the House and leaving
the country when it's shutdown I don't
think that's appropriate especially
especially the speaker thinks we
shouldn't even have the State of the
Union I think the best thing that could
happen in everybody couldn't calm a
little bit get in a room together and
put the American people first before
their travels and solve the problems
remember again and again including
yesterday Democrats refused to go to the
White House at the president's
invitation and remember that weekend
when the Vice President was staying all
weekend to negotiate with Pelosi and
Schumer they just sent their aides they
didn't want a solution of the problem so
leader McCarthy is right Speaker Pelosi
should be embarrassed she claims that
she cares about furloughed government
workers but she tried to postpone
shutdown negotiations so she could take
her government-funded international trip
she pretends that her fellow Democrats
are ready to open the government
immediately but allow dozens of her
colleagues to take that luxurious
lobbyists paid extravagant tropical
vacation of Puerto Rico there's the ones
with lobbyists corporate executives and
guess what you can see right there
Senator Bob Menendez of New Jersey he's
next to the woman in the bikini
does that look like a man that's worried
about furloughed employees of the
government its all-expense-paid vacation
well that's only ten days into the new
Congress vacation paid for 10 days in
well nice gig if you can get it so only
$1 for the wall and the wall is immoral
Nancy Pelosi pretends that a partial
shutdown is a major crisis somehow made
ample time where was she over the
Christmas holiday vacationing in Hawaii
president urged her to come to the White
House meet face to face to negotiate he
stayed in Washington gave up his
vacation
she obviously doesn't care about the
furloughed workers and she obviously
doesn't care about reopening the
government and what's worse she doesn't
care about the ROO
cause of the shutdown which is border
security this is literally for many
Americans life and death when angel moms
and dads families yesterday those that
lost loved ones at the hands of illegal
immigrants went to her office to visit
with speaker Pelosi she was in the
office she refused to come out and even
meet them yesterday and then you got
fake Jake Tapper over at fake News CNN
and he's rushing to speaker Pelosi's
defense why I don't know take a look a
White House official tells CNN that
Pelosi and members of Congress are
welcome to fly commercial to Afghanistan
a remarkable statement given that the
president just announced to the world
including the Taliban that the Speaker
of the House was headed there no he
actually told him she's not headed there
unless she wants to go commercial so
Nancy Pelosi
she's obviously playing playing politics
with the safety the security of all
Americans all because she just hates
Donald Trump remember Democrats sounded
like Donald Trump four years ago so yeah
it might be pretty easy to make this up
on fake news CNN and their friends in
the Democratic Party to call border
security they'll use the same phrase
manufactured crisis really manufactured
tell that to the face of angel moms and
dads that were on this program on Friday
all of whom lost their kids because of
illegal immigration and sanctuary
policies you know the facts paint a very
different picture now over the past two
years approximately 4,000 criminal
aliens have been arrested for homicide
30,000 for sex crimes over a hundred
thousand for violent assaults in just
2018 alone 17,000 individuals with
criminal records were apprehended trying
to cross the border we also saw a
hundred and twenty-two percent increase
in fentanyl being smuggled across our
southern border Americans are dying
every day from overdoses at least three
hundred now over the last few weeks over
twenty thousand children were smuggled
or trafficked into the United States and
as you can see for so many this is
literally life and death angel mom's you
know know what they're never gonna see
their kids again that's permanent
separation remember the Democrats they
seem to care about the issue of child
operation but only when they could
politically bludgeon President Trump who
in the end fix that problem one that he
inherited from their beloved Barack
Obama they never criticized him now some
victims will never recover
but this doesn't impact Democrats who
are safe and secure on Capitol Hill
living it up or taking junkets to Puerto
Rico that's why many of them have no
problem calling border walls they're
actually saying walls that protect both
sides immoral so I guess it's easy to
play politics when you're not impacted
you're not affected it hasn't been your
family and that's probably why Nancy
Pelosi's district has now become covered
look at this we sent our cameras from
the Hannity show over to Nancy Pelosi's
district we showed you last night human
feces needles while she's up there in
Washington DC raising money playing
politics without tackling any real
serious important issues this is what
her district looks like take a look when
you have needles and blood-stained
clothing in the streets that can't be
safe for anyone I do see like a lot of
needles and then no feces everywhere and
then that's obviously about drugs and
stuff like that kind of makes it a trap
when you walk around you see needles and
a playground and just feces everywhere I
mean the smell of it all it's definitely
have to look on the ground when you're
walking and it's been it's it's
definitely an uptick because I've lived
in the city in more than 30 years and
this is probably the worst I've seen it
Pelosi's district liberal utopia pretty
despicable
now given that Nancy Pelosi's massive
net worth her and her husband it's over
30 million dollars that's her district
well she could take some of that money
build a homeless shelter in her district
so that homeless people maybe can get a
bite to eat maybe sleep take a shower
use bathroom facilities why not fix the
problem in her district oh that's right
liberals are only generous with other
people's money mmm forgot that she's too
busy hating Donald Trump she's too busy
calling walls to protect this country
from 90% of the heroin that comes in
through our southern border she called
the walls immoral but tonight we're
seeing
some fractures now forming in the
Democratic Party including Pelosi
second-in-command
that's Majority Leader Steny Hoyer watch
this we've supported a substantial
restraints we've supported offensive
we've supported other technologies this
is not an issue of morality a wall is
immoral if it tries to imprison people
who shouldn't be in prison okay that the
text people is not anymore works it's
actually good to see a rare moment of
common sense from a member of the
Democratic Party but sadly this is an
anomaly this is pretty unusual this
party has now been hijacked by the most
radical individuals including devout
socialists and bigoted anti-semites and
lawmakers who want to dismantle
literally the US Constitution it's
beginning to be a pretty scary picture
and yesterday we saw a publicity seeker
far-left freshman congresswoman
Alexandria Acacio Cortes filming herself
storming into the Senate Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell's office she's demanding
that he reopened the government watch
this we're marching over to Mitch
McConnell's office and show him what's
up is that right
we went to Mitch McConnell's office
where we went to the Senate quote
where's Mitch you can run but you can't
hide
now when Acacio Cortez is not busy
plotting her next publicity stunt
well she's teaching her far less
media-savvy colleagues how to do the
same because yesterday she hosted a
Twitter one-on-one class for her fellow
Democrats because I guess they don't
have other pressing issues to deal with
she's not teaching them Twitter and
let's not forget Acacio Cortez is the
same member of Congress who literally
wants to take all of your hard-earned
money to pay for what our reckless
wasteful big government programs even
floating a 70 percent income tax rate
for some Americans dan bond Geno had a
great suggestion
we'd like to echo here on this program
Acacio cortez let her lead by example
she can donate seventy percent of her
income right now give it to the
government after all of salary is a
sitting member of Congress it's actually
triple the median income for an entire
American family
so Cascio cortez well you want to take
everyone else's money will you donate
your own will you actually put your
money where your mouth is
or better yet will you take a trip maybe
go to Cuba or Venezuela and see how your
socialist utopia is working in action oh
that's right you can't because of the
extreme conditions like crime and civil
unrest and crumbling infrastructure now
they even ran out of toilet paper in
Venezuela last year because of socialism
the entire country is going hungry
because of socialism they don't have
basic medical supplies because of
socialism do you really want that for
America how well did that work out for
the former Soviet Union now sadly Acacio
cortez is not the only Democrat with
these radical views it's actually
getting much worse for example many
Democrats including presidential
contender Kirsten Gillibrand get this
actively participating side by side with
a well known anti-semite by the name of
Linda Sarsour remember Sarsour she has
been known to praise and promote Sharia
law well we know what Sharia does for
women gays lesbians Christians and Jews
that's right all persecuted she rants
about so-called Zionists in Israel she
said that
ayaan Hirsi Ali doesn't deserve to be a
woman and deserves to have her female
and that have he taken away you may
remember that Ali was a victim of female
genital mutilation and when she was
accused of blatant anti-semitism she
blamed quote the Jewish media that's
Kirsten Gillibrand's friend Saur Saur
now her along with Tameka Mallory and a
few others they are now the founders and
the lead organizers of this coming
weekend's women's March in Washington DC
they're both avid fans of the bigoted
hate monger anti-semite racist Louis
Farrakhan Mallory even calling Farrakhan
the greatest of all time on Twitter now
a reminder here's the person often
praised by the founders of the women's
March coming up this Saturday take a
look here the Jews don't like Farrakhan
so they call me hidden well that's a
good name Hitler was a very great man
The Satanic Jews they control everything
mostly everybody there were many
Israelis and Zionist Jews in key roles
in the 9/11 attacks say the Jews have
control over those agencies of
government the powerful Jews
[Music]
and according to recent reports though
women's March actively coordinated with
Farah Khan's Nation of Islam for
security and other purposes and on the
view this week - Mika Mallory refused to
condemn this hate preacher racist
anti-semite take a look the women's
March unequivocally condemns
anti-semitism bigotry and Anne Farrell
remarks about Jewish people yes and we
have repeatedly in statement after
statement this year which are available
directly on our website for anyone to
read that'll speak for Jewish people but
I think I'm just confused these are
marks are I mean it goes on death to
Israel over and over again we did not
make those you can't so sitting with a
man what have like what I will say to
you is that I don't agree with many of
Minister Farrakhan statement
specifically about Jewish people as I
said I don't agree with many of Minister
Farrakhan statements you condemn that me
I don't agree with the statement at the
end of the day he won't condemn it
organizers of the women's March and
until recently the DNC was sponsoring
this March coming up Saturday they knew
it was run by bigoted anti-semites but
only now that it's out in the open the
DNC has cancelled their partnership but
laughably they all acknowledged the
reason for the cancellation now believe
it or not Democrats have a long history
with Farrakhan in fact remember not that
long ago President Bill Clinton recently
appearing right there on stage with
Farrakhan Obama was pictured hanging out
with this hate preacher just prior to
his time as president by the way they
hid this picture from you the American
people for eight years and sadly the
Democrats close relationship with
anti-semitism well it doesn't stop there
you have freshman congresswoman Omar is
also a known anti-semite once called
Israel an apartheid state and that's
just the tip of the iceberg watch this
you wrote Israel has hypnotized the
world may Allah weaken the people and
help them see the evil doings of Israel
we've comment did a lot since then
trying to explain what you meant by that
and I wonder just what your message is
this morning as the first on our
game-changer series to
Jewish Americans who find that deeply
offensive
oh that's a really a regrettable way of
expressing that I don't know how my
comments would be offensive to two
Jewish Americans your new radical
extreme Democratic Socialist Party in
America Pelosi Chuck Schumer you proud
to call this anti-semitic Democrat
colleague of yours
and when congresswoman Omar's not
trashing Israel so he's attacking
Republican Senator Lindsey Graham
because of his support for President
Trump without any evidence she tweeted
quote they got to him he's compromised
and on CNN she had a hard time
explaining her disgusting allegations
take a look he is somehow compromised to
no longer stand up for the truth it's
important to make sure that he is
fighting to protect the oath that he
took in serving the American people but
that's quite a charge to make you say
you're pretty sure based on based on
what evidence what what facts that
that's a remarkable comment to make
about a sitting u.s. senator the the
evidence really is present to us it's
being presented to us in the way that
he's believing again just based on what
evidence congresswoman my my tweet was
just an opinion based on what I believe
to be visible to me well as Nancy Pelosi
happy with this radical party of hers
and these conspiracy theories this party
is now a disaster America better wake up
but those Democrats do not have your
best interests in mind and now we turn
out to our Hannity watch on our deep
State tonight we reported last night
John Solomon and the Justice Department
official Bruce or admitting in
congressional testimony that he warned
the FBI brass and DOJ brass that that
dirty trump dossier was in fact
political opposition bought and paid for
by Hillary Clinton and the DNC and that
the document was likely tainted with an
anti-trump bias because Christopher
Steele had a personal animus towards
Donald Trump but it was still submitted
months later to the FISA Court as the
bulk of information despite never being
verified a corroboree
so what does that mean our own gregg
jarrett explains it in a new column
tonight it means that most prosecutors
knew that the Russian lies in the
dossier was the product of biased
deception and Greg will join us later in
the program we'll talk more about it
also means that James Comey Sally Yates
rod Rosenstein and all the others while
they appear to have made a conscious
decision to make
materially false statements and lie and
commit a fraud on the FISA Court this
must be investigated and handled the
rule of law must prevail and actively
concealing pertinent information and
failing to disclose those judges that
any of this in the FISA application on
Carter page they presented it as full
and truthful and they knew the exact
opposite they abuse the FISA warrant
process that is a violation of America's
constitutional rights and it undermines
a duly elected president now remember
James Comey told the president the
document was unverified and salacious
well that was in January of 2017 he
signed off on it as accurate in October
of 2016 and William Barr once you're
confirmed as the Attorney General you
must do your job you must investigate
this and in this two-tiered justice
system